the mask wars are back the mask wars are
back and everyone thinks we're all
fighting about science but we're not
fighting about science we're fighting
about
politics president trump you may have
seen it when he
beat the china virus in three days and
using only the power of mcdonald's
french fries and his pure coffee
president trump flies back to the white
house and films this cinematic video
where he gets back he gets off the
helicopter he walks up to the portico
and he takes the mask off
so this could be a movie trailer for a
michael bay movie i mean this is
pretty pretty well shot pretty
intense high budget high energy
marine walks off the president walks off
notice by the way everyone's still
wearing masks at this point when they're
all close to each other
gets up to that portico huge
shot from beneath and then the mask is
off he salutes
[Music]
there's a lot to this message i know i
mean we're kind of joking that it's like
some
giant 200 million dollar michael bay
movie or something but
there is a lot to this message which is
the president is willing to take
prudent steps if he's got this virus and
he's next to a marine but then when he's
out there in the open on the portico
he's going to take it off he's not going
to live in fear of this thing
when there's no reason to bill de blasio
filmed a response video to this
seriously like a teenager on youtube
filming a response video
he steps outside of gracie mansion i
take it or outside of city hall
and he walks over to his portico and he
puts his mask on
holding up the mask for everybody to see
[Music]
then he puts it on it's kind of a funny
idea it's just a lame
performance then he salutes
the people then he walks back inside
[Music]
so this is one mistake the left makes
generally which is that trump sets the
conversation and then everyone reacts to
it
it's kind of a funny idea right if you
if you have this political disagreement
again notice i'm saying not a scientific
disagreement
a political disagreement about the masks
trump says we sh we the mask is a symbol
you shouldn't be afraid of the virus you
shouldn't live your life cowering in
fear
and then the left saying you should be
very very afraid stay in your apartment
don't go anywhere
if you have that political disagreement
it's kind of funny to post that response
video except that
trump is setting the tone right so
everything he's just
shot for shot he's just performing the
the trump scene same thing with joe
biden joe biden
has a side by side he posts it to
twitter trump on the left biden on the
right even that
even that as a matter of stagecraft very
stupid for the left
because the left side of the screen is
the stronger side of the screen
it's the same reason that stage right so
when you're in the audience the people
who are on the left
is the stronger side of the stage we
read left to right
and he puts trump on the left and he
puts biden on the right and trump is
taking the mask off
biden is putting the mask on in
california they've taken this
to the craziest extreme they posted a
psa
from the office of the governor of
california saying
going out to eat with members of your
household this weekend don't forget to
keep your mask on
in between bites do your part to keep
those around you healthy
slow the spread that sounds like a great
way to get marinara sauce all over your
mask i have this idea of
you're you go out to an italian
restaurant you go you get your spaghetti
and meatballs you know you've got your
mask on then you lower your mask a
little
you slurp up the spaghetti and meatballs
the sauce going everywhere you've got
this filthy mask but that that will keep
you safe
obviously at this point they are just
trolling us nobody seriously thinks
that you should have your bite of pasta
and you kind of
lower the mask you put it in and you
pick it back up touching your face the
whole time
nobody nobody seriously believes that
and obviously gavin newsom
not a scientist not a medical expert
he is a politician i hope you enjoyed
that short segment from the michael
knowles show be sure to check out the
full episode linked in the description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts